bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa dj oggi ragazzi
faccio un gioco finalmente serio è
uscito m exodus non ancora neanche
aperto ragazzi quindi completamente
all'oscuro di quello che sto per andare
a giocare tra l'altro prima di
cominciare volevo dirvi che se volete
provare il gioco i link per la lascio
ringrazio m exodus per aver
sponsorizzato questo video proviamo a
vedere come partiamo ragazzi
milano milano l'ambientazione della
milano bellissimo quando c'è smog credo
sono uno di quelli che controlla le
fogne perché in qualsiasi gioco entro
nelle fogne
perché ha spiegato i ragazzi salve lei
per caso e di qua mi date una mano a
capire come sopravvivere no forse non ne
siete spero io posso andare in giro così
che figo che secondo me sono tutti morti
per noi ha le valige sono appoggiati
dalle non ce l'hanno voglia di
sopravvivere
mi va bene ho visto gente che andava di
quali però non è hai visto può passare
qualcuno
ho visto gente che co demonio porco
ritornando al nostro hobby preferito
perfetto salve
dovete morire vedo anche che ride di
gusto quando lo fai che non mi sorprende
per niente anzi farei lo stesso ragazzi
no no no no no era nino seriamente
dall'altra parte gli scherzi hirai
rainis per cortesia
andateci non sto scherzando sui laghi
per favore che schifo
ecco pure il desktop missile per tu
perché mi si apre adesso no
basta basta basta avete rotto le avete
scassato il bene basta ecco questa cosa
la vorrei fare sempre se così dove si
compra quest'arma io e bara preferisco
tempo
veramente dedita di brutto anche puoi
sparare con quella roba chiaro non era
un filmato l'ho fatto veramente io sono
proprio forte qualcuno mi toglie i ragni
da questo gioco per favore con ricordi
aiuto è morto per la prima volta effetto
sono decisamente contento di questo
gioco se chiudi la porta in fretta
magari non muori perfetto spara spara mi
va bene anche così come è bene che si è
entrato nelle fogne spiegano qual è il
problema
ma basta quanta gente grazie ragazzi no
veramente non so come ringraziarvi
magari metteteci sei ore la prossima
volta
ma perché uno si chiama idiota scusami
giudizio che si chiama idiota veramente
mannaia grazie dottore per tutto quello
che hai fatto ha iniettato del ketchup
sono sincero ragazzi la prima volta che
gioca un metro fino no non so se altri
personaggi c'entrano con gli altri m
però io non continuo a non capire perché
quello si chiama idiota vi prego
spiegato è vero perché non lo sto
capendo cioè veramente il suo nome
una settimana dopo abbiamo bevuto tutti
belli tranquilli io sono fuori come
sempre
torniamo a casa volentieri si anch'io
sono d'accordo però mi sa che sta per
succedere qualcosa in 3 2 1 c'è gente
sia tesoro c'è gente a iaia porco
demonio porco
tutto a posto amore ho pulito ma le
ragazze lo dobbiamo scappare da tutta
sta gente perché lhc un tizio ma noi un
è una talpa morta anche se non so come
si chiama in gergo però simpatico
ragazzi ho abbandonato beatamente mia
moglie nel a nola demonio notte come
cosa dovrei fare
aiuto tesoro devi sparare fortissimo
devi sparare veramente dove stanno
scappando tutti e che c'è ma secondo me
semplicemente stanno scappando da
qualcosa perché sono scappata 2 l'amore
cosa è successo
senti siccome io non so dove stiamo
andando puoi andare avanti tu mi fai da
gps
comunque siccome non so il caso siamo
riprecisato babilmente google non
funziona più quindi non c'è più google
maps by dimmi tu dove dobbiamo andare io
seguo tesi a cioè amore amore sconta mi
ecco e non me la cavo molto che non sono
molto atletico ma dove questo napoli
ecco lo vedi cola sei tu quando non ti
trucchi la mattina se avessi modo un
treno e non lo so vorrei andare a vedere
se hai voglia in ormai andato via
hai visto che c'è gente che non mi crede
nessuno mannaia la morte stavo cadendo
si si bea corri venisse riesci a ma non
devi spingere bene
invece di andare di prendere me perché
non corri verso il treno velocissimo
grazie no porca vacca era un imboscata
dai ha fregato anche me vabbè quindi
allora loro era sono dei sopravvissuti
che cercano altri sopravvissuti invece
non pensavano ci fossero evidentemente
ci sono ma sono più stronzi di noi
perfetto grazie per la scazzottata di
prima non so come ringraziarvi
eccolo perfetto c'era che non è per un
cane è tranquillo affrontato gente molto
più grossa di un di un cane boi ragazzi
questa è la m spero vi sia piaciuto arca
vacca siamo morti tutti sono ancora vivo
io no mi hanno ammazzato la moglie non è
vero siamo morti tutti
no non è vero mai credo che mia moglie
se ancora vi sopra ancora viva
mi sono beccato un proiettile in faccia
non è stato proprio simpatico però vabbè
mi servirebbe ragazzi un'arma fuci cose
per difendersi e ci sono pipistrelli che
se diventano più grossi potrebbe essere
un problema
e niente ragazzi entrano nelle fogne
perché in fondo è la mia passione questa
non so se avete notato comunque ragazzi
volevo dirvi che nel caso volesse
provare m hexus vi lascio sempre linking
descrizione siamo c'è un'accusa paul mio
dio c'è un mamma mia questo era
veramente grosso
avete delle armi da regalarmi fa anche
rima sarà questi sono nemici proprio io
non solo devo affrontare i mostri pure
degli esseri umani
porca vacca io non ho capito se mia
moglie è morta o no sta cosa non l'ho
capita vi giuro
siamo all e troverò mia moglie la
salverò tantissimo
ciao sono una persona
aiutami aspetta aspetta lo conosci tu
sera e basta non era più l'argomento è
venuto un nuovo psi madamin arma per
favore una qualsiasi arma una norma non
posso portarti all'ingresso principale
proprie guardie ma potremmo intrufolarsi
dal retro ok ma puoi aprire la porta ma
comiche soci avessero team senza fretta
se di nota non siamo entrambi spacciati
va bene
stop segue zio megan una sana e sotto la
luce ma la spagna la migliori tis track
tu vai al pannello magari di
illuminazione
quando vado è arrivarci ora ho capito ma
c'è un tizio l'io è orbo è veramente
cieco
la gente in questo gioco non vede meno
male
grazie mamma mia biglie ero veramente
titubante ragazzo vivo non so per quale
motivo bene andiamo
eccola ci arrivo ci arrivo tesoro sono
qua porca vacca fatto un casino per
arrivare qui l'amore ei tool porco le
vale le mani di dosso e questo da bill
armi la mia arma laminar ma non è più
bello dell'altro
beh vladmir comandiamo è morto e sono
storie d'amore prendi l'altra arma se c
hai voglia se c hai voglia a chi non
muore si rivede so che ti volevi libera
liberale di mero sta però che culo orcal
h ma come ti permetti
brava tesoro brava spara linee ciapet
sparagli io gli avrei già sparato io gli
avrei sparato molto brevi dai un'arma
muore per favore tanto ecco a noi erano
con lui
se sì è vero vero bene a scappare a
ragione un vecchio amico hanno lasciati
soprattutto vecchio questa è la mia arma
non è mia programmazione prima piace
riprendano ancora una cosa mi sta dando
cos'è sta roba marche attraverso il
cortile senza farti vedere in uso alla
porta delle barche qui va bene yermack
andiamo va bene
gasport cavalca ragazzi quanta gente
devo fare è una missione sterzi questa
calcio i tristi incredibile ma che
dobbiamo muovere ciapetti in una maniera
incredibile che si scava ancora nel
territorio deve entrare lì orca vaccari
sparano porri aiuto a mia porta
mamma mia quanto tempo ho fatto e ho
fatto ho fatto non mi hanno ucciso per
uno o più colpi e bisognerebbe ricordare
anche la gente mi ha visto un tratto dei
coltelli
lo chef tony è passato di qua ragazzi il
problema è buongiorno non credo di aver
capito adesso ho capito che è stata
bellissima la reazione proprio spang c'è
un nemico va bè ragazzi proviamo con un
approccio più stealth tra l'altro quindi
passiamo di sotto che magari serve di
più è ficcata al fatto che se ci vado
dietro lui non mi sente solo per gli
altri non mi sentono soprattutto il
rosso come sa che devo correre dargli
una botta perché non ce la faccio sono
uscito tutto perfetto fra gli arm aprì
la marmara ma non perfetto perfetto
perfetto perfetto ho fatto una cosa
incredibile che non mi riusciva mai più
di cori
mai più in tutta la vita di qualsiasi
videogioco non riuscirà mai più
grazie grazie mille ecco speriamo di
salvi la partita adesso che un miliardo
e mezzo di colpi non mi finiscono più
qualcuno qua sta dormendo che fa sei
morto così stai pensarci non posso
spararti alla catena come faccio a
liberarti è lo zio
se non ci fossi io quindi devo fare
comunque fuori tutti alla fine grazie
zoro bene hurley guida il treno ma che
storia via via via attiviamo i
meccanismi quindi e questo check point
ufficiale o un miliardo di colpi zia
fatto fuori tutti sono rocky balboa cioè
rambo fattore lo stesso però vorrei
vedere se riesco anche a lanciare tipo
de marco vacca
mia moglie è pazza mia moglie va in
faccia la gente
mamma mia mi voglio veramente impazzita
non oso immaginare quando le sue cose
caja porco demonio porco che male mi hai
fatto grazie ai colpi però un peso di
alto livello non li vedo tesoro sono
bravissima che donna tesoro po più caldo
ok
calma calma ha detto calma a mare di una
giornata che stiamo rischiando la morte
8.000 volta e non so se è normale
possiamo essere una coppia normale
magari se ci alziamo invece di morire
nell'inferno visto che non è proprio il
safe quindi io sono partito col treno
hai visto
secondo me adesso si aggrapperanno tutti
al treno dobbiamo farli fuori sono un
veggente sono un veggente ci hanno
proprio bene anche ho provato a lottare
ci ha buttati giù subito
[Applauso]
le signore qui abbiamo un problema a una
gamba di metallo sono loro tutti quanti
fate silenzio tutti non riesco davvero
non riesco e mi hanno sparato poi mi
hanno buttato un po difficile
va beh almeno adesso siamo liberi guarda
lato positivo cioè siamo sappiamo di
queste cose
quindi possiamo andare a farci una gita
è lo so che i soci di sono sempre
raccolto a 0
orca vacca un incidente di treni mi
mancava ragazzi
no c'è ancora gente ma dai veramente ma
basta che casino aiuto anche vacca
ragapiano b sparare sparare basta
sparare a vista molto bene
orca vaccaro ci sono sono arrivato in
tutto sto casino vai vai tienitela
regalo una bomba c'è un fuochista
possiamo scappare in tutto questo ciao
questa volta salta il treno deve
allenare se non muoio a devo frenato io
dobbiamo raggiungere altro trans
maschietto che un piacere 31 effetto
come si dice in questi casi è meglio
apprezzare il botto hanno però non stai
ancora escludendo ragazzi uno fa esplora
assomiglio che farò
vabbè è stato è stata una bella città mi
è piaciuta same c'è anche mio cane
potevate che il mio amore amore mio hai
visto
ho fatto un casino oggi che guarda rambe
in confronto è un tutorial 5 insomma è
fantastico sopravvive ai proiettili
sopravvive alla free endzone sopravvive
i treni che esplodono tutto ciò lo
traditori pericolosi lottatori nemici e
possiamo anche se non ci laviamo sono ok
va bene
quindi ragazzi direi che posso
concludere qua è fighissimo mi è
piaciuto un sacco in realtà non avevo
mai giocato m se conoscevo metro 2033
tra l'altro un sacco di gente nero
sempre chiesto di giocarlo però non non
l'ho mai fatto e non so perché molto
figo molto figo soprattutto il fatto che
c'è la storia alla fine che deve piacere
ma a me tutto il post apocalittico mi fa
mi ha sempre fatto impazzire un po meno
i ragni però quel problema mio
però ragazzi ho una voglia in orc a un
suocero che mi vuole bene che cosa
voglio di più dalla vita io non lo so vi
ricordo che permettono exodus vi lascio
il link in descrizione cose da ragazzi
servito più sull'argomento vi piace
anche vari social comunista tale
descrizione se non si dà così discrete e
noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
vita da ragazzi
[Musica]